the three mothers is about alberta king
burtis baldwin and louise little the
mothers of mlk junior james baldwin and
malcolm x and i wrote this book to not
only celebrate these three incredible
life stories that we should have known
for years and years before my book but
to also think about what their stories
could symbolize for black women black
mothers mothers more generally and what
it could mean to save their stories from
being forgotten from being erased and
how it changes our understanding of
where we are as a nation today how we
have arrived here what are changes that
we still need to make
that's great i mean i think in reading
it you can feel
how really lovingly you put all of this
together and did this research and and
uh the the attention that you you put to
this really comes through in the the
finished product um well we have we have
a question from jeff jeff says that uh
as a father this talk changed my life i
bought the book a few copies and was in
the audience in december live um and it
generated this concern for me um how
much history was impacted with lack of
mother's input especially black mothers
and that's a that's the question
that's a big question first thank you
jeff i really appreciate that so much of
our history we are missing these stories
and
the feeling that you felt in being in
that audience and that i felt in
uncovering these stories and every piece
of the puzzle that i found um that
just really you know shocked me that we
didn't know these things already and
infuriated me and really caused me some
deep sadness because i realized
how many more stories are i mean we're
missing so many and of course not
everybody's going to be famous not
everyone's going to have a book written
about them but it's very very
unique this erasure of black women's
contributions it is very intentional
like i said with hidden figures as an
example
why would we not know that black women
were the mathematicians called the
computers behind a space launch that is
critical information for our history and
for me to think as a young black woman
when i was sitting in school when i was
a young black girl what that could have
meant to me to know that
that it was a part not only of i could
not be just you know the first black
women to do something but that there was
a history before me
of black female mathematicians and these
brilliant brains and even as much as you
know my parents educated me on my black
history and my african history because
even i have a privilege that many black
americans do not have i knew my
connection to my lineage in ghana et
cetera so much of this history has been
robbed from us and it's a very strategic
robbing it's not a mistake um so that
just thinking from that perspective we
want to continue to uncover
more and more stories of those who have
been intentionally marginalized
intentionally oppressed
because the more we can correct our
telling of that story and that history
the better we'll do moving forward so
these attacks on telling
history right now it's very strategic
it's not again a mistake it's not
something that people are doing
unconsciously it's very we don't want to
tell the truth and we all need to reckon
with that and we need to fight against
that i think that it's really
interesting in the book that you thought
you draw these parallels between
uh what was happening in the lives of
these three women uh and what we're
seeing happening you know play out in
the news today or have seen happen at
other moments in history uh during
during their lives um and you know i'm
curious to hear how you think uh writing
this book changed your perspective on uh
the experiences of mothers currently
just how how you think about um
motherhood today
yeah and this is something that i
already knew was an issue um going back
to my mom she would always say in every
place that we travel to pay attention to
how women are being treated in the
society how mothers very specifically
are being treated that is an indicator
on how successful this community will be
and so i always carried that in the back
of my mind i was always aware that when
i moved back to the us for instance that
we weren't really giving mothers the
support that they deserved we weren't we
certainly weren't giving them the
celebration that they deserved and
therefore the support was lacking
and there was this lack of understanding
around the critical importance of the
role um but in putting this book out
there and
even doing the ted talk and speaking to
so many different audiences around this
it is a dire situation for mothers and
whether that's on a personal level where
those who have come up to me and said
i am the mom who feels unappreciated in
my household right now i am the mom who
feels unseen
um to this national level of a crisis
where
we are fighting for weeks of parental
leave mere weeks this is
it's upsetting and we should be
embarrassed by that these are things
that should have been established by now
um and i really do and i say this in the
ted talk i truly hope that within my
lifetime we can usher in a shift that
starts with first saying
mothers are essential
we need mothers to be supported because
they are holding so much of our lives
together our society together stay at
home moms are performing some of the
most important work in our country and
we are devaluing them and not only that
we are making them feel bad about what
they are doing um this really is it's an
issue that more of us need to take on
going back to that very first question
why this is an issue for
everybody to care about and it sounds
obvious but we shouldn't have to say
that
if mothers are dying in a maternal
health crisis one that is exacerbated
for black women the black maternal
health crisis is alarming
but generally the maternal health crisis
in the us is is terrible it shouldn't be
this way mothers of of all races are
dying more than they they should be
um we need to pay attention to that
that's not only bad for mothers
obviously it's not only bad for mothers
if they have to walk away from their job
during the pandemic because there were
no supports in place to catch them
it's not only bad for mothers if they
have to choose between
being a mother or making money for their
family if that shouldn't be put on their
shoulders there should be supports in
place we should have affordable child
care we should have
universal preschool all of these things
that impact mothers have ripple effects
for the rest of us so yes i it opened my
eyes to just how alarming and how
critical the situation
we're currently in even though again my
mom raised me to know all of these
things
through doing this work i've just now
been
kind of awoken to
the need for people to open their eyes
right now
and watson has a question that actually
kind of piggybacks on this uh more than
just thinking about how we can gain
access to these stories um they want to
know you know what do you feel is the
most effective way we can as a people
change the narrative around black women
um you know if you have any uh specific
examples which i know you share some of
your your talk um how can i they ask how
can i personally uh be involved in this
work of changing this narrative
great question and
there are levels to this i would say
definitely understanding the history
of
how black women have been treated is
very important so again not a it's a
shameless plug but read the book because
i talk about
not only these three women but again
many of the goals that i had one of them
also was to explain tropes like um
the mammy and the matriarch trope and
the
jezebel trope and the welfare queen and
the strong black woman trope what all of
these have
meant in american history and what their
intention was and that
is to
say that anything black women were
dealing with was their own fault
that
with the miami trope that we didn't
deserve necessarily to be
compensated for work that we were doing
that we deserve to stay within domestic
work and that we shouldn't necessarily
be paid what that work was worth um
because we liked it that we were happy
to be the miami the anjamaima who was
smiling and wanted to do
you know wanted to serve her white
family more than her own um the
matriarch trope that black families are
have been separated from each other not
because of systems that have made it so
that you know mass incarceration or so
many other things that i could mention
but instead because black women were
emasculating their men or the jezebel
trope that justified sexual violence
against black women because that's what
black women wanted they were more
promiscuous even the welfare queen
saying black women are having children
just to make money so you have to
understand this is a very long
ugly
painful history that we are dealing with
as black women
day in and day out and when people don't
get that that is the those are the
burdens we are holding years and
centuries of being told that everything
that's happening to you the pain you're
going through
is because of you
and not because of policies we've voted
for or the ways in which we've kept you
from being elected or even being able to
run for office or even vote
um
that's where it really begins like take
the time as much as you can to know
how we've gotten to where it is right
now and then
to really have a moment where you fully
appreciate the incredible resistance of
black women and the ways in which we've
continued to create life despite the
ways that people have tried to rob it
from us and the vision behind what black
women have been able to
accomplish what they have imagined for
this world because we can't accept the
situation as it is right now because
that dehumanizes us but we have pushed
this nation forward to our vision in
incredible ways it's not only stacey
abrams in georgia it's a long long
history of black women saying we don't
agree with the system as it is now so
here's how we're going to help you see
the world and the possibilities from our
perspective and you look at american
history from that angle
and it is
powerful it is
there is nothing like it and therefore
you better understand why we should
elect more black women
why we should vote for them um to help
usher our country and continue to do it
but with even more support and even more
backing because without that backing
without that support when black women
have been erased and misrecognized
misrepresented we have still created
incredible change so now we're asking
that we be heard we'd be listened to and
that our energy no longer be spent on
explaining how we got here but instead
on how we can do whatever is next and
whatever's possible
so a kind of combination of
try to learn our history
support us as leaders
put those tools in our hands as much as
possible trust us hear us believe us and
also stop wasting our time on the the
need to
explain the extra when that's work that
we can do on our own that kind of brings
me full circle to my research thing
around i didn't reach out to the family
until i'd done my part
so yeah i mean even attending a
conversation like this is part of doing
your part so so kudos to you all we're
all we're all starting
today that's doing your part to sort of
to educate yourself um on
information that already exists out
there it sounds like um beyond what we
could do individually to educate
ourselves and make change in this space
how can we what can we expect from our
government um you know to do more on the
national scale and then even thinking um
globally what are some things that uh
you would like to see so that we change
the way that we as a culture think about
black motherhood for this one because
i'll give a quicker answer than i have
in me because you can tell i like to
talk
and i can go for a long time um but
in the book the concluding chapter is
entirely about
what we need to do as a world and what
are the lessons that alberta burtis and
louise's lives are teaching us about
our next steps forward when it comes to
policy when it comes to actually even
kind of this three level
layer that i like to talk about which is
the interpersonal level is an important
one the conversations that we're having
with each other and the stories that
we're telling um when i you know in the
ted talk a little snippet where we have
mothers who feel
like they have to be selfless and that
we celebrate mothers for being selfless
so even around mother's day we say to
moms thank you for sacrificing
everything for me and for putting
yourself behind everybody and
yes a lot of others have done that and
certainly if they have we should thank
them for that but what we can start to
do is shift that that story and that
thank you and say
you know thank you for doing everything
you could do for us and also thank you
for still seeing yourself as a human
being or for representing yourself as a
human with a full range of emotions and
for teaching me about
um my first life lessons for being my
first caretaker for being my first
leader for being my first teacher like
those are things that i think more
accurately represent mothering in a way
that that is sustainable for mothers
where mothers aren't going to burn out
um where we're not putting all of it on
moms and then reiterating it by saying
thank you for putting yourself behind
everyone else so that's on like an
interpersonal level i do think those
conversations can make a huge difference
um in terms of what mothers are even
thinking is the goal of what we're
trying to achieve and what we want to be
thanked for
um
the second level of that is you know in
relationships even beyond our households
and
what we can and i mean like you said in
terms of black motherhood very
specifically
this burden of like putting our needs
behind everyone um i just did a piece
for new york magazine on this that that
is further exacerbated for black women
because we have been seen as the mothers
of
a movement we're always like mothers of
something much larger and not just like
mothers of our own children
but this weight of what's placed upon us
and specifically in this article i'm
focusing on mothers whose children have
been killed
whether by police officers or
neighborhood vigilantes and
how in these moments instead of giving
these moms this space to grieve
we're asking them to do something for
our entire country you know we ask them
to speak to crowds they run for office
which can be a part of their personal
healing as well but we interpret that as
look at what this black woman is doing
for all of us rather than us thinking
about what is she going to do for her
own healing for her own restoration
um so so that's kind of the extra layer
to that um and then thinking about it on
a national level what we're voting for i
think about
what could have helped alberta
burtis and louise and what we still need
to this day right now so to give a
little bit more information on the women
alberta king
had to walk away from her job because
the law stated at the time that married
women were not allowed to teach and
she'd always had this dream of being an
educator
she had a bachelor's degree she had a
teaching certificate um but when she met
her husband she made the decision to
start a family um because this was like
she had to make a decision and even
though that law the marriage bar is not
in place now
what are the many ways in which we're
pushing women and mothers out of their
jobs there are many that still exist and
we need to start addressing those if we
look at these are just one example from
each woman if we look at british baldwin
she was the victim of an abusive husband
for years
years and years and
james baldwin speaks about this often
how abusive his stepfather was
but she didn't have anyone she could
really turn to because especially in
black communities we are so afraid of
what might happen if we call a police
officer
um and we have multiple examples of this
where we really needed help and
intervention and then somebody ends up
being shot when they're called when
police officers are called to protect us
um
so bertis baldwin was aware of this her
children had been harassed by police
officers james baldwin tells the story
of when he was pushed into an alley and
he was maybe 11 years old and police
officers searched him because they were
looking for someone and just left him
there on his own little boy so she's not
going to call them to help her in this
situation so she just endures this abuse
all on her own so what are systems we
can think about in terms of should there
be other people we can call
um who are not police officers should
there be
you know more
support even for social workers that
could come out um
that's something to think about and and
to reflect on and then as an example for
luis little a very i mean all three of
them have these different painful
traumas that they experience and for
louise one of the major ones is that she
is put in an institution against her
will for 25 years of her life because
she was this activist radical activist
who spoke up against white supremacy who
stands and faces off with the kkk
literally um and a white male physician
was sent to her house to evaluate her
after her husband
had been murdered and
he concludes that she's experiencing
dementia and in his doctor's note he
says that she is quote
imagining being discriminated against
imagining being discriminated against
this is a black woman black immigrant
woman living in the midwest
um and that is enough to put her away in
an institution against her will so in
terms of us thinking about the biases
that black women are facing
when they
don't ask for help even and people just
decide they're going to come in and
evaluate them especially even when they
do
that they're going to be misunderstood
that they're going to be told they're
imagining things
these are things we need to address so
we also have to do an evaluation of our
health care systems and the biases that
still exist so it's kind of like this
endless list and i definitely don't want
to end on such a heavy and hard note but
in that concluding chapter
it's called our lives will not be erased
um that's where where i go with it is
policy and what we have and what we can
do kind of some tangible next steps
well i mean and i i think that's so
important and so valuable and um
to your point of not ending on a such a
in such a heavy place you know i guess
how do you feel though about the
progress we are making um em watson asks
you know do you feel that the black
women narrative is progressing i am an
optimist and i often say that my
optimism lies in this incredible
uh activism that black women have held
for so long and who
we continue to envision new realities
for this world and that makes me really
hopeful um to study alberta burtis and
louise who again it's not ancient
history burtis passed away in 1999
louise passed away in 1991 um so this
isn't like ancient ancient history but
they did face a lot of things that i no
longer face as a result of their work
and a result of what they were able to
accomplish and how they taught their
children to accomplish these things and
change the world so i'm not the kind of
person who thinks
we are stuck and there is no forward
progress that we've made
i feel like that would be really
disrespectful to them if i felt that way
because they gave as much as they could
to that progression and it's my turn to
carry that forward as well
um but what i do hope is that more
people join us in this and that black
women are not continuing to have to do
this
on our own um that more people will
be aware of history i sound like a
broken record but be aware of history so
that we can move forward and and fight
anything that tries to keep us from
telling
accurate
um and full
representations of our country's history
um because i think if we're aware of it
then we won't want to repeat it and we
we have more people who will want to be
allies in this fight
and in my contribution to this i'm just
hoping i'm giving more of us tools to
join the conversation and think about
how we can carry it forward
[Music]